- [Instructor] This right over here
is the graph of y is equal
to absolute value of x
which you might be familiar with.
If you take x is equal to negative two,
the absolute value of
that is going to be two.
Negative one, absolute value is one.
Zero, absolute value is zero.
One, absolute value is one.
So on and so forth.
What I wanna do in this video
is think about how the
equation will change
if we were to shift this graph.
So in particular, we're
gonna first think about
what would be the equation
of this graph if we shift,
if we shift three to the right
and then think about how that will change
if not only do we shift three to the right
but we also shift four up,
shift four up,
and so once again pause this
video like we always say
and figure out what would the equation be
if you shift three to
the right and four up?
Alright, now let's do this together.
So let's just first
shift three to the right
and think about how that
might change the equation.
So let's just visualize what
we're even talking about.
So if we're gonna shift
three to the right,
it would look like,
it would look like this.
So that's what we first wanna
figure out the equation for
and so how would we think about it?
Well, one way to think about it is,
well, something interesting is happening
right over here at x equals three.
Before, that interesting
thing was happening
at x equals zero.
Now, it's happening at x equals three.
And the interesting
thing that happens here
is that you switch signs
inside the absolute value.
Instead of taking an
absolute value of a negative,
you're now taking the absolute value
as you cross this point of a positive
and that's why we see a
switch in direction here
of this line
and so you see the same thing
happening right over here.
So at this point right over here,
we know that our function,
we know that our equation
needs to evaluate out to zero
and this is where it's
going to switch signs
and so we say, okay, well, this
looks like an absolute value
so it's going to have the form,
y is equal to the absolute
value of something
and so you say, okay, if x is three,
how do I make that equal to zero?
Well, I can subtract three from it.
If I say y is equal to the
absolute value of x minus three,
well, let's try it out.
Let's see if it makes sense.
So when x is equal to three,
three minus three is zero,
absolute value of that is zero.
That works out.
When x is equal to four,
four minus three is one,
absolute value of one is indeed,
is indeed one.
And if x is equal to two,
well, two minus three is negative one
but the absolute value of that is one.
So once again, I'm showing you this
by really trying out numbers,
trying to give you a
little bit of an intuition
because that wasn't obvious to
me when I first learned this
that if I'm shifting to the right
which it looks like I'm
increasing an x value
but what I would really do is replace my x
with an x minus the amount
that I'm shifting to the right
but I encourage you to try numbers
and think about what's happening here.
At this vertex right over here,
whatever was in the absolute
value sign was equaling zero.
It's when whatever was in
the absolute value sign
is switching from negative
signs to positive signs.
So once again, if you
shift three to the right,
that has to happen at x equals three.
So whatever is inside
the absolute value sign
has to be equal to zero at
x equals three and this,
pause this video and
really think about this
if it isn't making sense
and even as you get more
and more familiar with this,
I encourage you to try out the numbers.
That will give you more,
instead of just memorizing,
hey, if I shift to the right,
I replace x with x minus
the amount that I shift.
Always try out the numbers
and try to get an intuition
for that why that works.
But now, let's start from
here and shift four up
and shifting four up is in
some ways a lot more intuitive.
So let me do that.
Let me shift four up.
Alright, so let me move.
I'm gonna go up one, two, three and four.
I think I got that right.
So now I've shifted four up.
And just as a reminder
of what we've even done,
the first part we shifted
three to the right
and now we are shifting four up.
So now, now we are shifting four up.
So before, y equaled zero here
but now, y needs to be equal to four.
So whatever this was evaluating,
do we now have to add four to it?
So when we just shifted
three to the right,
our equation was y is
equal to the absolute value
of x minus three
but now whatever we were getting before,
we now have to add four to it.
We're going up in the vertical direction.
So we just have to add four.
Now, this makes a little bit more sense.
If you're shifting in
the vertical direction,
if you shift up in the vertical direction,
well, you just add a constant
by the amount you're shifting.
If you shift down in
the vertical direction,
well, you would subtract.
If we said shift down four,
you would subtract four right over here.
The less intuitive thing
is what we did with x
'cause when you shift to the right,
you actually replace your x
with x minus the amount that you shifted
but once again, try out numbers
until it really makes some
intuitive sense for you
but this is what we would finally get.
The equation of this thing right over here
is y is equal to the absolute value of x
minus three plus four.